well the Ukrainian president of Vladimir
zielinski earlier today denied any
involvement in the crash
when Ukraine was reaching out to other
countries regarding the planes this is
not what we had in mind I'll tell you
honestly we had something completely
different in mind we wanted support
although perhaps this may also help in
some way we don't have any connection to
this situation that's for sure I think
everyone understands who is involved
to cave in Ukraine where we can speak to
our correspondent there Rob McBride just
uh before we spoke to Kristen Rob we
heard from Vladimir zielinski he was
denying any responsibility for Ukraine's
role or saying there was no role of
Ukraine in the death of pregosian
yeah absolutely this latest statement
from Vladimir Putin is being regarded
with extreme cynicism uh here in Ukraine
you know this is uh we've had 24 hours
of Silence from the Kremlin about
somebody who is not an inconsequential
character on the Russian scene if
anything you know this is a creation of
the Russian system you've had Russian
state-run media lionizing uh the
apparent victories of uh of Wagner on
the battlefields of Ukraine especially
on the uh Eastern front uh suddenly it
the the his apparent demise is being
talked about by all of the world's media
we've heard from Sergey lavrov that this
is just the the imaginations of Western
media if you like and there's nothing
really to discuss but the absolute
relative silence within Russia itself
Silence from the Kremlin and then
suddenly just in this almost understated
way a meeting between Vladimir Putin and
the senior official saying oh yes about
the Avia Asian incident isn't it sad
about this a patriot him and other
Wagner leaders who are doing their
patriotic Duty talking about him but
very in an understated way and almost
saying there's nothing else to see here
please move on there is an official
investigation and a an official inquiry
report will come out in due course we've
heard from Vladimir zielenski the
Ukrainian president in a press briefing
earlier today to Mark Independence Day
it's a public holiday here in Ukraine
saying that as far as he is concerned
Ukraine has had nothing at all to do
with this saying that everybody knows
who was involved the view here from Kiev
is that this has the Fingerprints of the
Kremlin of the Russian leadership all
over the demise of yevgeni Prego and Rob
just up to speed with what the role now
of Wagner in Ukraine is
up
well it's very interesting officially
there is no Wagner here in Ukraine or
any of the Russian controlled parts of
Ukraine it has ceased to exist as an
organization we know that in this a spat
with the Russian military where the
establishment and the ministry of
Defense there was this effort to get
Wagner soldiers to sign contracts with
the the Russian defense Ministry it's
unclear exactly how many Wagner Fighters
have done that have gone over and signed
contracts because of course many of
these Wagner Fighters are former Russian
soldiers who have left the Russian
military for whatever reasons many of
them wanting nothing more to do with the
Russian military establishment
preferring uh the the more swashbuckling
life of a private mercenary that's far
better paid and so on so it's unclear
exactly how many of these Wagner
Fighters have gone back to the Russian
Ministry of Defense how many of them now
may have signed for for regular Russian
units and be fighting on Russian soil
but as officially at least the wardner
structure does not exist here it does
exist north of here in Belarus and
clearly there are concerns just about
what this might mean whether this leads
to another period of insecurity uh do
Wagner Fighters may be taking take on
some sort of Maverick role along the
northern border between Ukraine and
Belarus do they take their fight back to
the Kremlin which would cause
instability within Russia internally
which may take some pressure off the
lines here which might be welcomed by
the Ukrainian military if you have a
Resurgence of this Mutiny type activity
by these Wagner Rogue Wagner units as we
saw a couple of months ago so it does
remain unclear we've been talking to
people out in the streets this is a
public holiday here it's Independence
Day we've been it is a hot topic of
conversation being given pre-gos means
notoriety a lot of people have been
talking about this is a top story in the
media here about just what happened to
him and about his demise a lot of people
we had spoken to said well it doesn't
really matter we're still at war with
Russia whether those are Russian Wagner
Fighters or Russian uh regular military
units that is still our existential
struggle a fight that we are involved in
that will continue a lot of other people
uh seeming to indicate quite cynically
perhaps that there was an inevitability
about this that pregojin in his very
public fight with the Russian defense
Ministry that he embarked on several
months ago basically set the clock
ticking ultimately leading now to his
ultimate desire demise okay Robert
McBride talking to us there from Kiev
thanks very much Rob